in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some cryptocurrency fans
with their data store transaction it's
at the right time to invest in the
performance market stay tuned to find
out like many startups today coin all
the things is writing the cryptocurrency
wave and in order to provide real-time
dashboards they mirror all validated
blockchain transactions back to
datastore so that customers can look at
historical records sadly though they
quickly ran into an issue with their
readwrite performance being limited to
only about one entity update per second
far slower than what they needed
thankfully I was able to reach out to
some fellow advocates who were able to
help track down the problems after a few
emails and a couple hours of looking at
their tech stack we were able to
pinpoint a critical optimization for
their datastore usage transactions and
batching see in a hurry to get their
code up and running coin all the things
did a lot of copy pasting from sample
references and ended up in a place where
each of their calls executed as a single
action and since each request has its
own transactional overhead this quickly
became the bottleneck during high
performance workloads the solution of
course was to batch these sets of calls
together into a single HTTP request so
the overhead is lowered across the
entire set of updates now there's two
primary ways to do batching in datastore
the first is transactions which allow a
set of operations to be atomic that is
either the entire set succeeds or it
fails so there's no chance of half of
the update to have occurred which is
really helpful when wanting to enforce
consistency to your observers sadly
though transactions are only limited to
a set of 25 operations at a time this is
where the batching API is come in they
don't have the same size restrictions
and they don't do updates atomically so
observers should take eventual
consistency into account when
interacting with the database now
head-to-head we can see that both
transactions and batching outperform
their linear counterparts but to be
clear here each of these tools are
valuable for a specific use case and
shouldn't be adopted universally without
understanding the trade-offs now for
coin all the things the choice was clear
they split some of their operations
between batching and transactions
depending on the consistency model they
need
and saw performance skyrocket along with
their ICO value if you'd like to know
more about these topics check out the
article listed in the description below
and don't forget to check out the rest
of the cloud performance Atlas content
because when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts